Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Cutters. This is section 10 of the beating chronic Lyme book.
To hope you're learning a lot from this. If nothing else you learned to
find a doctor that you can get a prescription of antibiotics and even keep them in your medicine cabinet and utilize
if you feel like you're in that acute stage. That window can be so brief. It can literally be hours on some patients.
Typically it's weeks. Sometimes it can last as much as a month, but usually it's only weeks.
So even if you went in right away and got a test that took a week or two to get back, you could have missed the window.
Just a crime, a horrible crime. Find somebody that's Lyme literate that will prescribe you antibiotics based upon their
wisdom.
We're talking a little bit about chronic stage Lyme in this section. So there's lots of different protocols out there.
I have some of the books. I believe I'd have it see protocol.
Catsclaw is probably one of my favorite catsclaw,
Echinacea and garlic. That's why I have them out here.
Though there's multiple different, I believe the counten's protocol.
Well, there's just a lot of different protocols out there. All of them are for treating chronic Lyme,
but unfortunately many of those protocols do dot
separate out whether the person's in an autoimmune Lyme. They don't even know about it. We talked about that.
That's the problem. So if these protocols work for you and they've been consistent and worked really well for you,
you are probably not reading this book. So if you are reading this book, you're probably having struggle.
You've tried these some of these different protocols and you still have problems. You are most likely autoimmune.
So that's one way to tell. So the biggest question that we get, how do I test if I'm in phase three if I'm in autoimmune?
Well, you don't need to necessarily do cytokine testing and such like that.
Really, if the, if the TH1 stimulants make you worse, your TH1 dominant.
So, um, again, just using that clinical information.
You don't need to come to me and get that testing done even.
Matter of fact, I do not accept patients just for testing. We're just too busy for that.
We only set except patients for our entire care package.
So we just, I just don't have time to do that.
So that's why we put on this, I created this presentation so that you learn how to do this without necessarily needing by help that way.
If you're stuck in a situation where you've tried a chronic program like this and it still has not worked for you,
you're most likely autoimmune and then if you want my help, you could look at our office and, and, and come in and get care.
And we talk about what we do in our office in the next couple of presentations in the rest of this book.
But again, treated this is really treat acute phase line as soon as possible with antibiotics.
If, again, the immune stimulants of any kind make you worse, you're probably in phase three and you're going to need further help.
So this is where you're going to call us or you're going to try to use some of the protocols in this book.
And by all means, give it a try.
Just do not stimulate a TH1 response, you will make yourself worse.
You could kill yourself that way, please.
Not understanding the immune system is really bad.
So this is everything I taught you in this, any of the doctors that I talked to, don't understand that.
So this is immunology 101 really and you need to become an expert.
Sometimes you need to be your own doctor.
So read the section and I will see you at the next section.